>>>CHANTIX PRESENTS, REAL
STORIES, REAL PEOPLE.
>> I'M KELLY, AND I QUIT SMOKING
WITH CHAN TICKS.
>> KELLY IS A REAL CHAN TICKS
USER.
SHE IS NOT AN AL QAEDA ACTRESS.
>> WELL, ACTUALLY, IT'S FUNNY
YOU SAY THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW, I
USED TO BE AN ACTRESS.
>> BUT SHE'S NOT ANYMORE.
SHE'S JUST HERE TO GIVE A
TESTIMONIAL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> UNLIKE OTHER METHODS, CHAN
TICKS WORKS BY REDUCING THE URGE
TO SMOKE.
>> THAT'S AN URGE I USED TO GET
CONSTANTLY.
BUT CHAN TICKS WAS DIFFERENT.
SORT OF LIKE MY TAKE ON OPHELIA
IN THE VILLAGE PLAYERS'
PRODUCTION OF HAMLET.
>> BUT THAT WAS JUST COMMUNITY
THEATER.
SO LET'S GET BACK TO CHAN TICKS.
>> IT WON AN AWARD, SO --
>> FOR ACTING?
>> WE WON FOR COSTUMES.
HAHA, NOW THAT I QUIT SMOKING I
HAVE MORE ENERGY TO DO THE
THINGS THAT MATTER TO ME LIKE
GARDENING OR WORKSHOPING
CHARACTERS FOR MY ONE WOMAN
SHOW.
BUT DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT.
ASK MY NANA FROM THE OLD
COUNTRY.
>> OH, YOU SHOULDN'T NOT SMOKE.
>> BUT WE ARE NOT TALKING TO
THAT PERSON.
WE ARE TALKING TO KELLY, ABOUT
CHAN TICKS.
>> WHEN I HAD KIDS, I KNEW I HAD
TO GIVE UP SMOKING.
WHEN I TRIED QUITTING WITHOUT
CHAN TICKS.
I WAS LIKE --
>>CALLY SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
HER SUCCESS WITH CHAN TICKS
BECAUSE SHE'S A REAL PERSON, NOT
AN ACTRESS.
>> WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL, I
TOLD MYSELF, YOU ARE GOING --
YOU ARE GOING TO BE SOMEBODY.
>> NO ONE IS BUYING IT, KELLY.
>> DAMN IT.
>> SIDE EFFECTS OF CHAN TICKS
MAY INCLUDE NAUSEA, FATIGUE --
>> IT IS A BOOM BOX.
FINE, IT'S A BOOM BOX.
>> DRY MOUTH, AND KIDDING
YOURSELF ABOUT YOUR LEVEL OF
TALENT.
>> HERE'S THE THING.
I I WILL DO NUDITY, FULL, THE
TOP AND THE UNDER.
THE WHOLE NINE.
>> CHAN TICKS, REAL STORIES,
REAL PEOPLE.
NOT ACTORS.
>> I'M TALKING FULL BUSH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]